[Music]
warner brothers sent the entertainment
industry reeling earlier this month when
they announced that their full slate of
movies for 2021
will be simultaneously released in
theaters and on the streaming service
hbo max
while it's unclear just what lasting
effects this move will have for the
future of film
it will undoubtedly ripple out to affect
the industry on multiple levels
even going as high as the top act does
in the business fueled by the pandemic
shutdown of movie theaters and filming
this latest move is hardly the most
unlikely development in a year full of
uncertainty for entertainment companies
actors directors and everyone in between
while production has mostly resumed the
traditional release strategy deployed by
distributors
remains precarious movies that were
expected to be huge blockbusters
like disney and marvel's black widow
have had their release dates pushed back
while others have been sent straight to
streaming christopher nolan's tennis
distributed by warner brothers was the
biggest film this year to release
exclusively in theaters
since the pandemic started and it didn't
do great at the box office
so warner brothers took a different
route with wonder woman 1984
delaying it twice before they settled
definitively on a december
25th release on both hbo max and in
theaters at the same
time under the assumption that this
decision will result in fewer ticket
sales
warner brothers won the film's major
economic players in advance
including the theatre company amc and
agents representing the film star gal
gadot
and director patty jenkins according to
the hollywood reporter and the new york
times
they agreed to give gaddurt and jenkins
more than 10 million dollars each
to compensate for the percentage of box
office sales they would normally receive
however since warner brothers announced
it will be using this hybrid release
method for all 17 of its upcoming films
in 2021
they have reportedly not made similar
deals with the a-list actors headlining
those titles
via the new york times generally actors
received two paychecks for a film
one guaranteed and paid up front and the
second contingent on the film's
performance and financial return
since theater companies have been
suffering under fought shutdowns and
lower attendance throughout 2020 and it
looks like these issues will continue
into
the new year that second check for
2021's films is looking to be slimmer
than any actor expected
when they first sign their contract
while warner's films will only be
available on hbo max for a month
the simultaneous release will likely
shave even more off that second paycheck
presumably warner brothers made the 10
million dollar deal with gadettes to
make up for that discrepancy
but now with highly anticipated films
like june and the matrix 4 going the
same route as wonder woman 1984
warner brothers has not offered the
stars of those films the same deal
as the new york times reported this
includes a-list actors such as keanu
reeves
denzel washington angelina jolie and
will smith
the agencies representing them were only
given some 90 minutes of notice
before the announcement went out to the
press which could sour relationships
between these actors and the studio
it could also lead to ugly litigation
since big agencies and big stars
tend to have pretty decent legal
representation hbo
max which first rolled out in may has
struggled to compete with the litany of
other streaming services available
according to cnet it hit only 8.6
million subscribers
in its first five months compared to
disney plus there's 50 million in the
same time frame
although hbo max has to pay warner
brothers for the rights to stream their
films
they're ultimately both owned by the
same parent company warner media
some agents think warner brothers should
have approached at the streaming sites
to find the best licensing price
but now it's unclear if these actors
will receive any portion of a potential
hbo max subscriber increase
exactly how these fees might be a
portion than a future compensation
structure
is likely to be the charge of some
unfortunate team of studio accountants
while the wonder woman 1984 decision was
not ideal
it was accepted as a necessary move
because of the pandemic
however the 2021 deal is frustrating
agents and theater companies
because there's an expectation that
moviegoers will return to theaters
sometime next year
vaccines for the coronavirus have
already started rolling out
and the assumption is that they'll be
widely available next spring
in this line of logic that could mean
movies slated for a late 2021 release
date
could have had a more normal opening but
warner brothers has preemptively altered
that for its own films
audiences may choose to simply stay at
home instead of heading to theaters
it remains to be seen if any other
entertainment companies like disney
will follow warner brothers lead but
perhaps they're waiting to see how
wonder woman 1984 performs
either way it's bad news for movie stars
and even worse for theaters in general
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one